Oklahoma's top prosecutor blames
corporate greed for what he calls the
worst man-made health crisis in US
history and a first of his kind trial
the state argues Johnson and Johnson
used deceptive practices to fuel an
opioid epidemic that has killed more
than 200,000 Americans in the last two
decades
Omar Villafranca is at the courthouse in
Norman Oklahoma
Omar what did we learn from the trials
very first day good morning we learned
this is going to be a full-contact trial
both sides came out swinging during
opening statements and this is the first
of roughly more than 1,800 similar cases
to go to trial so there's a lot of
attention from state's drug makers and
people affected by the opioid crisis but
nothing Emily Walden did could save her
son TJ a member of the Kentucky National
Guard from an ultimately fatal opioid
addiction that's what brought her here
from Kentucky for the start of this
landmark case the stage Oklahoma
Attorney General Mike hunter is asking a
judge to hold Johnson & Johnson liable
for creating a public nuisance
contributing to the opioid epidemic
through deceptive and misleading
marketing in opening remarks he accused
the company of running a brainwashing
campaign to downplay opioid risks money
can make people and businesses do bad
things
the state says drug makers push
clinicians to prescribe opioids making
more than one hundred and forty nine
thousand sales visits to fewer than
2,500 prescribers Purdue Pharma and tivo
Pharmaceuticals previously settled out
of court without any admission of
wrongdoing our evidence is going to is
going to show clearly and irrefutable
that these companies work together and
that Johnson and Johnson was ended up to
their neck Johnson & Johnson says its
drugs were designed to be difficult to
abuse and only comprised a miniscule
share of Oklahoma's opioid market and a
defense lawyer argued there's no proof
that company's actions directly caused a
single addiction or death and how many
we
take for us to be responsible for a
nuisance a public nuisance
despite settlements with other drug
companies the Oklahoma Attorney General
says there are currently no settlement
talks with Johnson & Johnson this trial
is expected to last two months
Anthony two months Wow all Mar thanks a
lot of people watching that trial very
closely